ينضم الينا من البيت الابيض منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي جون كيربي سيد جون اهلا بك نفذت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
ضربه على مواقع حوثيه في اليمن الرد
الحوثي جاء بانهم لن يتوقفوا عن استهداف
السفن في السفن الاسرائيليه والمتوجه الى
الموانئ الاسرائيليه ما الذي حققته هذه
الضربه
ما زلنا نقوم بتقييم الضرر الذي تحقق
حققناه فكانت عده اهداف ضربناها في اليمن
ليله امس وكل الاهداف كانت قد صممت لتقلي
وقدرات الحوثيين على اطلاق وصواريخ
ومسيرات على السفن في البحر الاحمر ونزل
ندرس النتائج ونعلم ان هذه اهداف جيده
وسنرى ماذا يكون تاثيراتها لاحقا اليوم
الحوثيون لديهم خيار كما قال الرئيس في
بيانه نحن لن نتردد لن نت اتخاذ المزيد من
الاجراءات للدفاع عن سفننا
وبحاره وايضا السفن الدوليه التي تفحر في
البحر الاحمر هذه لابد ان يقف هجمات عليها
يعني ذلك با امكانيه تكرار هذه الهجمات
لن لن استبق العمليات العسكريه باي طريقه
كل ما اقوله ان ان ننظر بشكل جديد جدا نحو
التزاماتنا لدفاع انفسنا و مصالحنا
والدفاع عن الملاحه الدوليه ونحن نحافظ
على حق اتخاذ المزيد من الاجراءات كما قال
الرئيس اذا كان ضروريا نامل ان ذك لن يكون
ضروريا ونامل ان الحوثيين قد فهموا
الرساله بان لن نقبل اي استمرار للهجمات
سيد كوربي المجلس السياسي الاعلى للحوثيين
قال ان كل المصالح الامريكيه والبريطانيه
اصبحت هدفا مشروعا لقواتهم ردا على ما
قامت به الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبريطانيا عبد الملك الحوثي زعيم جماعه
الحوثيين قال ان الرد سيكون اقوى مما كان
عليه سابقا بعد هذه الضربات الا تخشون ان
تؤدي هذه الضربات الى توسيع رقعه الحرب في
المنطقه ان الطرف الوحيد الذي يقوم
بالتصعيد وزياده التوترات هم الحوثيون
وطبعا هناك من يدعهم في ايران وكل ما
استطيع
قوله هو انني اسمع ما يقول انه ولكن اعتقد
ان وضحنا ليله امس
باننا ندافع عن مصالحنا بطريقه ج جدا
والحوثيون الان لديهم خيار لا نريد انيك
هناك تصعيد لا نريد ان نريد النزاع والحرب
وس على تحقيق ذلك في المنطقه ما نريده في
المنطقه كله هو مرور امن وسالم للسفن في
البحر احمر وهذا وتالي فهم يقولون السفن
التي تتوجه نحو اسرائيل بينكل هذا غير
صحيح هم يهاجمون حتى السفن التي متوجهه
الى اسرائيل اذا ف تصريحاتهم سخيفه ونحن
نتحمل مسؤوليه
دعا عنه المالح شكرا لك جون كبي منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي كنت معنا من البيت
الابيض